MALE SPEAKER: In this tutorial,
we're going to show
you how to obtain a refresh
token for testing your code
without having to write
the code to handle the
authorization flow yourself.
The first thing you'll want to
do is [? browse to the ?]
OAuth Playground.
The OAuth Playground is a tool
hosted on Google Developers
site that lets developers
see authorization flow
step-by-step and see
how API calls are
made at the HTTP layer.
You can find the OAuth
Playground at developers.googl
e.com/oauthplayground or by
searching for OAuth Playground
in your favorite
search engine.
For today's tutorial, we're only
going to show the steps
required to obtain a long-lived
refresh token that
we can exchange for access
tokens to make YouTube Data
API and YouTube Analytics
API calls.
The first thing we need to
do is configure the OAuth
Playground to use our client
secret and client ID.
Let's find our client ID and
client secret from the Google
API Console.
We're going to need
these in a second.
Browse back through OAuth
Playground and click the
Settings button.
Let's check the box using Use
Your Own OAuth Credentials.
And let's make sure the access
type is set to Offline,
because this is what we need
to ensure that we receive a
long-lived refresh
token and not a
short-lived access token.
You'll be presented with two
fields, one for client ID and
one for client secret.
Let's copy-paste the values
over from the API console.
There's one more thing
we need to set up.
Note that we have a redirect
URI set up that points to
developers.googl
e.com/oauthplayground.
This is important because the
OAuth Playground requires us
to redirect back through
Playground after an
authorization step.
Let's click on Edit Settings.
If we haven't set this yet,
let's enter this into the
Authorized Redirect URIs
box and click Update.
Now let's go back through
OAuth 2.0 Playground.
Let's select the APIs
to authorize.
Scrolling down, we're going to
select the YouTube Analytics
API, a read-only scope, and
the YouTube Data API v3.
Now let's click Authorize
APIs.
We'll be forwarded to
a page where we'll
need to grant access.
If we're in charge of multiple
channels, we'll first be
presented with an
account picker.
Let's click Accept
and continue.
We now have an authorization
code, which we can use to
exchange for a refresh token
and access token.
Let's click Exchange
Authorization Code for Tokens.
The OAuth 2.0 Playground will
populate the refresh token and
access token fields after
making the API call.
We can start using these
immediately.
But the value we want
[? to save for our ?]
scripts is in the refresh
token field.
As we can see, the access
token will expire
in about one hour.
The official Google API clients
will all handle
obtaining an access token for
us as long as we supply a
client ID, client secrets,
and refresh token.
And that's how we generate a
refresh token using the OAuth
Playground.